WELCOME BACK TO CROSS COUNTRY SO
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS I'VE
BEEN HAPPY TO SHARE NALA AND MY
JOURNEY WITH ALL OF YOU VIEWERS
AT HOME AND NOW AFTER COUNTLESS
HOURS OF HARD WORK AND TRAINING
QUEEN NALA OFFICIALLY MADE HER
WAY TO NEW YORK CITY.
AND FIRST THING WE DID WAS TAKE
HER OUT TO SEE THE CITY.
WATCH.
♪ ♪
SO WE'RE IN NEW YORK CITY.
I COME HERE PART-TIME TO DO THE
SHOW.
WHY WOULD WE WANT TO MAKE THIS A
TRAINING EXERCISE?
>> I'M STILL IN AWE --
[LAUGHTER]
, I MEAN, IT'S AMAZING TO WATCH
THE DOG FOR THE FIRST TIME COME
FROM WHAT WE CALL THE FARM --
ALL OF THE TRAINING ALL OF THE
FOUNDATION, GENETICS, AND A
PHILOSOPHY AND BRING HER INTO AN
ENVIRONMENT LIKE THIS.
AND HER HEADS TURNING LIKE MINE
IS JUST --
BUT EVEN THOUGH IT IS TURNING TO
DISTRACTION AND STRESSING SHE
REMAINS OBEDIENT AND TAKE YOUR
DIRECTION.
>> A CRAFTY LITTLE GIRL.
>> YOU KNOW HONESTLY BROTHER I'M
AUTOWATCH HER MOVE THROUGH THIS
ENVIRONMENT.
>> CHAOS IN THE CITY, AND PEOPLE
ARE LIKE ROAMING ALL OVER THE
PLACE AND THERE'S FOOD AND DIRT
AND THINGS THAT SHE SHOULD NOT
BE HAVING.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WHY WOULD WE PUT HER IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT?
>> I MEAN, THERE'S NUMEROUS
REASON WHY IS YOU WANT TO BRING
HER INTO NOT ONLY THESE
DISTRACTIONS BUT YOUR PATTERN OF
LIFE WHERE YOU GO IN NEW YORK
YOUR JOB WILL TAKE YOU TO ALL
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENTS THIS IS A
PERFECT OPPORTUNITY TO PROVE
THAT WITH THINGS NOT TO EAT
STREET CROSSINGS, RIGHT I NOTICE
A COUPLE OF UNDERGROUND PARKING
GARAGES CARS COME IN AND OUT
STOP WAIT, SEATS, ALL OF THE
FOUNDATIONAL TRAINING THAT WE'VE
PUT INTO HER NOW IT NEEDS TO BE
PROVEN AND TESTED RIGHT THAT'S
WHAT WE DO DOES IS WORK AS
DUPLICATE UNDER STRESS AND THIS
IS A --
BIG STRESS ENVIRONMENT.
>> SO WE TEST THIS --
STRESS TEST THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
REAL LIFE.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR AS
SHE'S IN HERE?
>> I'LL TELL YOU THE HONEST ONE
OF THE BIGGEST POINTS I'M
LOOKING FOR IS --
HOW YOU ARE COMMUNICATING WITH
HER SO YOU'RE NOT SITTING STILL
BUT YOU'RE TAKING OPPORTUNITY
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF EVERY
OPPORTUNITY.
SOME PEOPLE THEY DON'T MISS THE
MARK BUT THEY JUST DON'T SEAT
IMAGINE NICK IT.
YOU'RE NOT ONLY SEEINGS THE
MAGIC BUT CREATING WITH HER SO
AS MANY OBSTACLES AS YOU SEE YOU
JUMP INTO THAT OPPORTUNITY.
SO THAT'S THE MAGIC OF JUST NOT
ONLY SEEING WHAT WE'VE DONE WITH
HER.
BUT CONTINUING TO SEE WHAT YOU
AND HER ARE GOING TO DO ON YOUR
JOURNEY.
GREAT CHATTING WITH YOU BUT I
HAVE TO GET TO WORK LET'S HIT
THE SUBWAY SEE HOW THEY REACT.
LET'S GO.
♪ ♪
>> READY --
LET'S GO.
ARE YOU READY?
COME ON.
GOOD --
[LAUGHTER]
SO NALA IS HERE IN STUDIO.
I GOT TO THANK WITH K-9 BECAUSE
WOULD HIM WE COULDN'T MAKE THIS
POSSIBLE IT IS TRULY THE WAY IF
YOU LOVE NALA LIKE I DO YOU CAN
FOLLOW HER ON INSTAGRAM/AMERICA
K-9 SHE REALLY IS AMERICA'S K-9
REMEMBER WE'RE DOING THIS FOR
ALL OF THE VETERANS THAT
STRUGGLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND
THEY NEED ASSISTANCE WE'RE
TRYING TO GIVE THEM A K-9 AND I
KNOW NALA AND ANY OF THESE K-9S
WOULD CHANGE THEIR LIFE BECAUSE
SHE'S CHANGED MY LIFE THANK YOU
FOR WATCHING THFTION OUR LAST
SHOW OF 2022 BUT WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK HERE LIVE NEXT YEAR, BUT
UNTIL THEN FIND ME ON SOCIAL
MEDIA LAWRENCE B. JONES 3 SET
YOUR DVR SO YOU NEVER MISS A
SHOW AND DON'T FORGET US TO
SENDING STORIES AT CROSS COUNTRY
AT FOX.COM.
GOOD NIGHT AMERICA.
LET'S